This episode is one in a four-part series that we're calling the future of. We'll be exploring how changes of the way we live, learn, work, and play may shape our health and well-being in years to come. Thanks to the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation for supporting this episode. The Robert Wood Johnson Foundation is committed to improving health and health equity in the United States. Learn more about them at rwjf.org. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Hey Roman.
本集是我们称之为“未来”的四集系列节目之一。我们将探讨未来几年生活、学习、工作和娱乐方式的变化将如何塑造我们的健康和福祉。感谢罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会对本集节目的支持。罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会致力于改善美国的健康状况和健康公平。请访问 rwjf.org 了解更多关于他们的信息。这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。嗨，罗曼。
Hey producer, Delaney Hall. So you're here with the next story in our series called The Future of Dota Dota. And you're here to talk about The Future of Data. Yes, that's right. And I feel like I should just level with you and our listeners. This is a story about spreadsheets, okay? It's a story about spreadsheets and data entry and data systems. The story about spreadsheets is not even my birthday, Delini. How do I get this marvelous gift?
嗨，制作人德兰妮·霍尔。所以你带来了我们系列节目的下一个故事，叫做《Dota Dota 的未来》。你是来谈谈《数据的未来》的。是的，没错。我觉得我应该对你和我们的听众实话实说。这是一个关于电子表格的故事，好吗？这是一个关于电子表格、数据输入和数据系统的故事。关于电子表格的故事甚至都不是我的生日，德兰妮。我怎么能得到这份美妙的礼物？
I should have known I wouldn't have to convince you. You do not have to convince me, I'm already riveted, so let's go. Okay, so we'll start in the early days of the pandemic. Today, the entire city of Wuhan is on lockdown. And as COVID spread in Asia, and then in other parts of the world, weighing the most active hotspot right now, is Italy nearly two months. You were seeing officials take these wildly unprecedented steps
我早就该知道我不用说服你。你不需要说服我，我已经入迷了，我们开始吧。好的，我们将从大流行初期开始。今天，武汉全市处于封城状态。随着新冠疫情在亚洲蔓延，然后蔓延到世界其他地方，目前最活跃的热点地区正在权衡，意大利已经快两个月了。你可以看到官员们采取了前所未有的严厉措施
to control the disease, lockdowns, quarantines, massive amounts of testing. And I think a lot of people thought we'd see the same kind of response in the U.S. when the virus arrived here. You know, as someone who grew up reading the hot zone, I expected that we had the world's foremost infectious disease fighting agency in the world. This is Alexis Madrigal. At the time the pandemic started, he was a journalist at the Atlantic, and he's still a contributing writer there. So I was expecting to see the United States of America assume global leadership and come up with ways for us to deal with it. And like Alexis,
来控制这种疾病：封城、隔离、大规模检测。我想很多人都认为，当病毒到达美国时，我们会看到同样的反应。你知道，作为一个读着《血疫》长大的人，我曾期望我们拥有世界上首屈一指的传染病防治机构。这是亚历克西斯·马德里加尔。大流行开始时，他是《大西洋月刊》的记者，现在仍然是该刊的特约撰稿人。所以我期待看到美利坚合众国承担起全球领导责任，并想出应对它的方法。就像亚历克西斯一样，
and come up with ways for us to deal with it. And like Alexis, I was basically imagining scenes from outbreak and contagion in my head. You know, like brave epidemiologists and hazmat suits working with the best technology available to get a scary situation under control. And so of course we all wanted that to be the reality. We all wanted that to be what our pandemic response looked like. Here's Robinson Meyer, Alexis's colleague at The Atlantic. Right, the CDC seemed like the last version of like absolutely competent American technocracy. Right, like they were on top of it.
并想出办法来应对它。就像亚历克西斯一样，我基本上在脑海中想象着《极度恐慌》和《传染病》中的场景。你知道，比如穿着生化防护服的勇敢流行病学家，利用手头最好的技术来控制可怕的局势。所以我们当然都希望这成为现实。我们都希望这成为我们大流行应对措施的样子。这是亚历克西斯在《大西洋月刊》的同事鲁滨逊·迈耶。没错，疾控中心看起来就像是绝对称职的美国技术官僚的最后一版。没错，就像他们完全掌控了局势一样。
But as we started to see cases of COVID here in the US, Alexis and Rob felt like the response from our public health agencies was surprisingly muted. We were not seeing mass testing, like was happening in Asian countries. And in fact, when they started looking, it was hard to find any concrete numbers at all about how much testing was happening here. Which was not good because testing was the most crucial data point that we had for understanding the pandemic at this point. So I guess the CDC was not tracking that at the time.
但当我们开始在美国看到新冠病例时，亚历克西斯和罗布觉得我们的公共卫生机构的反应出奇地沉默。我们没有看到像亚洲国家那样的大规模检测。事实上，当他们开始寻找时，很难找到关于这里进行了多少检测的任何具体数字。这可不是什么好兆头，因为检测是我们了解这场大流行病所拥有的最关键的数据点。所以我想疾控中心当时并没有追踪这一点。
Well, at first it was, but then in early March 2020, the agency stopped reporting the total number of nationwide tests. And basically, they said, most testing is happening at the state level. So if you want to know, go ask the states. The CDC just wasn't saying. So I was like, fine, we're going to go to the states. So they reached out to all the states and asked some really basic questions, you know, how many people have you tested? How many positive cases have you had?
嗯，起初它是追踪的，但在2020年3月初，该机构停止报告全国检测的总数。基本上，他们说，大部分检测都是在州一级进行的。所以如果你想知道，去问各州吧。疾控中心就是不说。所以我当时想，好吧，我们要去问各州。因此，他们联系了所有州并询问了一些非常基础的问题，你知道，你们检测了多少人？你们有多少阳性病例？
And how many tests can you do each day? And they were shocked by what they found. Oh, man, we tested almost nobody. So what's that mean, almost nobody? Like, what are the numbers for almost nobody? Well, on March 6th, which was just a few days after the CDC stopped reporting testing numbers. Robin Alexis could only verify that 1,895 people nationwide had been tested for COVID.
你们每天能做多少检测？他们对自己的发现感到震惊。哦，天哪，我们几乎谁都没测。那“几乎谁都没测”是什么意思？也就是说，“几乎谁都没测”的数字是多少？嗯，在3月6日，也就是疾控中心停止报告检测数字几天后，罗布和亚历克西斯只能证实，全国仅有1,895人接受了新冠检测。
Even though the White House was saying that tens or hundreds of thousands of people could be tested per day by that point. So I do remember some of this. There was this huge shortage of tests for hospitals to use at the beginning of the pandemic. And there were pretty strict rules by the CDC about who could get tested at all, because you know, this test were in short supply. Yeah. And that ended up having enormous implications, because without much testing, it was hard
尽管白宫当时表示，到那时每天可以检测数万甚至数十万人。我确实记得其中的一些情况。大流行刚开始时，医院使用的检测工具极度短缺。而且疾控中心对谁可以接受检测制定了非常严格的规则，因为你知道，检测物资严重短缺。是的。这最终产生了巨大的影响，因为如果没有大量检测，就很难
to know what was happening on the ground. If you looked at the state of the data, there was no data. In many states, Kutesta does in people a day. If the virus was circulating, we had no way to know. And Alexis and Rob felt like they had wandered into this weird twilight zone, where people at the top of our public health agencies were talking about carrying out a data-driven pandemic response,
了解实地正在发生的事情。如果你看数据状态，就会发现根本没有数据。在许多州，每天只检测几个人。如果病毒在传播，我们根本无从知晓。亚历克西斯和罗布觉得自己误入了一个奇异的迷离时空，公共卫生机构高层的人在谈论开展数据驱动的大流行应对措施，
but without actually having much data. And it'd be like, well, it seems like the virus could be everywhere then, and they'd be like, well, the data doesn't say it is. But the data was sh- And it wasn't just the testing data that was limited. It was also hard to find numbers on how many people were hospitalized and how many people had died. And so Robin Alexis decided to team up with a guy named Jeff Hammerbacher. He's a scientist and software developer. And they started compiling their own nationwide data sets based on what states were publishing.
但实际上并没有多少数据。情况就像是，“嗯，那病毒可能无处不在了，”而他们会说，“嗯，数据并没有表明是这样。”但数据是被—而且不仅是检测数据有限。很难找到关于住院人数和死亡人数的数字。因此，罗布和亚历克西斯决定与一个名叫杰夫·汉默巴赫的人合作。他是一位科学家和软件开发人员。他们开始根据各州公布的数据，整理他们自己的全国数据集。
And they thought of this as a stopgap. These are not fancy things, right? Cases, hospitalizations, deaths, number of tests performed. Like this is basic stuff. Like you look around the world and like, all these other places just like have this stuff, you know? So we were just like, well, obviously,
他们认为这是一种权宜之计。这些都不是什么高档的东西，对吧？确诊病例、住院人数、死亡人数、检测数量。这都是基础的东西。就像你环顾世界，所有这些其他地方都有这些东西，你知道的？所以我们当时就觉得，好吧，显而易见，
we'll also soon have this stuff. Because how could you run a public health response without good data? It's like the lifeblood of public health, and it has been since the beginning of the field. Okay, before we continue with the saga of Rob and Alexis, I wanna tell you about some of that early public health history because some of it's fun.
我们很快也会拥有这些东西。因为离开了好数据，你怎么能开展公共卫生应对工作呢？这就像是公共费生（注：原文应为公共卫生）的命脉，自该领域诞生以来一直如此。好吧，在我们继续罗布和亚历克西斯的传奇故事之前，我想告诉你一些早期的公共卫生历史，因为其中一些挺有趣的。
Honestly, that's big reason, but also because it shows why data is so important. And why our system makes it so hard to collect. Okay, let's do it. Okay, so there were many innovators in the realm of health data, you know, people like John Snow, William Far, W.E.B. Du Bois. But I'm going to zoom in on one of the earliest examples. We'll start with John Grant and the Bills of Mortality. The Bills of Mortality. I like this one, this is very ominous. I like it a little bit.
老实说，这是一个很大的原因，但也是因为它展示了为什么数据如此重要。以及为什么我们的系统让收集数据变得如此困难。好吧，我们开始吧。好的，健康数据领域的创新者有很多，你知道的，像约翰·斯ノ（注：斯诺）、威廉·法尔、W·E·B·杜波依斯这样的人。但我将把镜头聚焦于最早的例子之一。我们从约翰·格兰特和《死亡统计表》开始。《死亡统计表》。我喜欢这个，听起来很不祥。我挺喜欢的。
So the Bills of Mortality were these mortality reports. They were published in London in the 1600s. And every week a group of parish clerks would gather and share information about who had died in the neighborhood and how. And people would read them and they would kind of pick up the local parish thing and be like, oh, you know, John died. So this is Stephen Johnson. He wrote a book called Extra Life, a short history of living longer. And he says the bills were a source of fascination for many people, people liked to gossip about them, but they weren't what you would call structured data. Like there wasn't a way to detect useful patterns in the information there.
所以《死亡统计表》就是这些死亡报告。它们于1600年代在伦敦出版。每周都会有一群教区书记员聚集在一起，分享关于邻里中谁死了、怎么死的的信息。人们会阅读它们，有点像是去拿当地教区的印刷品，然后说：“哦，你知道的，约翰死了。”这是斯蒂芬·约翰逊。他写了一本名为《超长寿命：更长寿的简史》的书。他说，这些统计表是许多人着迷的源泉，人们喜欢八卦它们，但它们不是你所说的结构化数据。因为没有一种方法可以从其中的信息中检测出有用的模式。
But then John Grant comes along and Grant was a Haberdashur slash amateur demographer. That's a very 1600s combination of interests. Yeah, you don't really get that kind of mix anymore. So he was a classic kind of engaged amateur and he looked at the bills of mortality and thought there is more to be learned from these documents. And so it occurred to him at some point in the early 1660s that if you try to assemble that data and look at it systematically, that you might be able to tell a lot more about what was really happening to the health of Londoners. And so he spent all this time going from
但随后约翰·格兰特出现了，格兰特是个杂货商兼业余人口统计学家。这是一个非常1600年代风格的兴趣组合。是的，你现在再也找不到那种组合了。所以他是一个典型的积极参与的业余爱好者，他看着《死亡统计表》，认为这些文件中还有更多东西可学。因此，他在1660年代初的某个时候突然想到，如果你试图将这些数据汇集起来并系统地查看它们，你也许能够对伦敦人健康状况的真实情况说出更多门道。所以他花了很多时间从
kind of parish to parish and reading through all these reports and kind of tabulating basically the data and trying to organize it in a more structured way. And Grant ended up publishing a pamphlet with a very catchy title. It was called Natural and Political Observations mentioned in a following index and made upon the bills of mortality. And what it enables both Grant to do, but also health officials around the city is to suddenly be able to answer the question, what is really killing people? You know, where are the real threats? And how are those threats changing over time? Grant's work represented a huge conceptual breakthrough. His pamphlet was basically the founding document of medical statistics and public health data. the founding document of medical statistics and public health data. But it ultimately wasn't that useful because there was still a limited understanding of what was actually killing people.
一个教区到另一个教区，通读所有这些报告，基本上把数据列表整理出来，并试图以更有条理的方式组织它。格兰特最终出版了一本小册子，名字非常吸引人。它叫做《对随后索引中提及并在死亡统计表上做出的自然与政治观察》。这不仅使格兰特能够做到这一点，也使全市的卫生官员能够突然回答这个问题：究竟是什么在杀害人们？你知道，真正的威胁在哪里？这些威胁是如何随时间变化的？格兰特的著作代表了一次巨大的概念突破。他的小册子基本上是医学统计学和公共卫生数据的奠基文件。医学统计学和公共卫生数据的奠基文件。但它最终并没有那么有用，因为人们对究竟是什么在杀害人们的理解仍然有限。
For example, let me share with you the causes of death tabulated in this report. The list is really pretty funny. According to Grant in 1662, about 1,300 people in London died of Apoplex, 38 died of Cut of the Stone, 74 died of Falling sickness, 243 died of Dead in the Streets. Only six died of Leprasy, actually, which is like you would have expected more in 1662. 158 died of Luna tick,
例如，让我与大家分享一下本报告中列出的死因。这个列表其实挺搞笑的。据格兰特在1662年所说，伦敦大约有1,300人死于中风，38人死于结石，74人死于癫痫，243人死于横死街头。实际上只有6人死于麻风病，这与你在1662年所期望的相比有点少。158人死于狂躁症（注：原文Luna tick即Lunatic），
and then my favorite category, 454 died of suddenly. You can totally imagine the scenario where you get the answer suddenly, you ask, you know, some official comes up and says, how do you die? And someone says, suddenly. Which is, I'm just right down suddenly.
然后是我最喜欢的类别，454人死于突然死亡。你完全可以想象这样一种场景：你得到了“突然”这个答案，你问，你知道的，某个官员走过来问：“你是怎么死的？”然后有人说：“突然死的。”也就是，我直接记下“突然”。
Totally, yeah, like I wonder if gradually shows up in the tabulations. Well, then I can see, if bad data comes in, there's not much you can do about that, but I can still see how it's groundbreaking. Yeah, it was groundbreaking in that it took these anecdotes and turned them into data about a population. But it wasn't actionable, partly because of answers like suddenly, but also because to act effectively on that data, they needed institutions that could coordinate
完全是这样，是的，就像我想知道“逐渐”是否也会出现在列表中。好吧，我能理解，如果垃圾数据进来了，你对此也无可奈何，但我仍然能看出它是具有开创性的。是的，它的开创性在于它将这些轶事转化为了关于人口的数据。但它无法付诸行动，部分原因是因为像“突然”这样的回答，也因为为了对这些数据采取有效行动，他们需要能够协调
a public health response. And those did not really come into being at least in the U.S. until the middle of the 19th century. at least in the US until the middle of the 19th century. In the 1800s, a number of cholera epidemics swept across the United States. And in response, cities and states across the country started to establish local public health departments. But the system here grew in a mostly bottom-up way. It was cities and states first. It took decades before any real national public health institutions came along.
公共卫生应对措施的机构。而这些机构直到19世纪中叶才真正诞生，至少在美国是这样。直到19世纪中叶才在美国出现。在19世纪，多起霍乱疫情席卷美国。作为回应，全国各地的城市和州开始建立地方公共卫生部门。但这里的系统在很大程度上是以自下而上的方式发展的。城市和州在先。经过了几十年，真正的国家级公共卫生机构才出现。
So when did the federal government began to get more involved with public health across the whole nation? Pretty late in the game. There was one national agency called the Marine Hospital Service, and it cared for sick and injured sailors. Eventually, in 1912, that agency became the Public Health Service. It started taking on greater powers, but it was still very hesitant to interfere in anything that was local. This is David Rosner. He's a historian of Public Health at Columbia University. The federal government is basically the weakest part of the national structure.
那么联邦政府是什么时候开始更多地参与全美公共卫生事务的呢？在整个进程中算是相当晚的。有一个名为“海军医院服务”的国家机构，它负责照顾生病和受伤的水手。最终，在1912年，该机构变成了“公共卫生服务局”。它开始承担更大的权力，但仍然非常犹豫，不敢干涉任何地方性的事务。这是大卫·罗斯纳。他是哥伦比亚大学的公共卫生历史学家。联邦政府基本上是国家结构中最薄弱的部分。
This was, you know, not a country that saw the federal government's much more than a bunch of buildings in a swamp in the DC area. Over the next few decades, the national system grew. The CDC eventually emerged from the public health service and became, in many ways, the best disease-fighting agency in the world. They pioneered the whole idea of a data-driven response, you know, using stats to figure out who was being hit by disease and how to intervene. It's this moment when a lot of American culture begins to turn to technology and science in general as a means of addressing all these very sticky social problems that plagued us.
这，你知道的，并不是一个把联邦政府看作不仅仅是华盛顿特区沼泽里一堆建筑物的国家。在接下来的几十年里，国家系统不断发展。疾控中心最终从公共卫生服务局中脱颖而出，在许多方面成为了世界上最好的疾病防治机构。他们率先提出了数据驱动应对的概念，你知道的，利用统计数据来弄清楚谁受到了疾病的打击以及如何进行干预。正是在这个时刻，许多美国文化开始转向技术和科学，以此作为解决困扰我们的所有这些棘手社会问题的方法。
And for that, you needed data. You needed some sense of what society looked like. So if you saw statistics that showed high death rates in one community or another, you could begin to rationalize your resources and identify resources. And the CDC had some huge successes. The agency helped eradicate smallpox. It started the fight against HIV.
为此，你需要数据。你需要对社会的面貌有一定的了解。因此，如果你看到统计数据显示某个社区或其他社区的死亡率很高，你就可以开始合理化你的资源并识别资源。疾控中心取得了一些巨大的成功。该机构帮助根除天花。它开启了抗击艾滋病的战斗。
It stopped Ebola more than once. And over a time, it developed a really heroic reputation. But there was always this underlying weakness in our system, which is that it's very fractured. It wasn't a coordinated system like some countries have. Instead, our system is this patchwork of thousands of state and local health departments who all operate pretty independently. So the CDC can issue guidance, but ultimately state and local health departments answer more to their local elected officials
它不止一次阻止了埃博拉病毒。随着时间的推移，它建立了一种真正的英雄般的声誉。但我们的系统中始终存在着这种潜在的弱点，那就是它非常破碎。它不像某些国家那样是一个协调一致的系统。相反，我们的系统是由数千个州和地方卫生部门组成的拼凑体，它们都相当独立地运作。因此，疾控中心可以发布指导方针，但归根结底，州和地方卫生部门对当地民选官员的响应，
than they do to the CDC. Yeah, I mean, it sounds like federalism as a concept is a real challenge to public health. Like a lot of power resides in the states and it's made that way, you know, on purpose. But I mean, when it comes to public health, these things don't have state boundaries. I mean, a flu or a COVID can pass through state boundaries and does not care about federalism at all as a concept. Right. Viruses do not care about states, right? They do not care about state jurisdictions.
要大于对疾控中心的响应。是的，我的意思是，联邦制作为一个概念对公共卫生来说是一个真正的挑战。比如大量的权力保留在各州手中，而且你知道，这是故意这样设计的。但我的意思是，当涉及到公共卫生时，这些事情是没有州界的。我的意思是，流感或新冠病毒可以穿过州界，作为概念，它根本不在乎什么联邦制。是的。病毒不在乎州，对吧？它们不在乎州的管辖权。
Over time, there was another damaging pattern that began to develop with the CDC and the public health system more widely, which was that it struggled for consistent funding. So when there was an immediate crisis, there would be an infusion of cash, but then when the crisis had passed, the resources would evaporate. And that only accelerated from the 1980s onward during the Reagan era. Yeah. Reagan is at the start of many of these things when it comes to like the social safety net being eroded. Yeah. There's a familiar story for a lot of agencies. Yeah. And you know, this is a complicated part of the story that we're not going to wade super deep into.
随着时间的推移，疾控中心和更广泛的公共卫生系统开始出现另一种破坏性的模式，那就是它一直在为获得持续的资金而挣扎。因此，当出现紧迫危机时，会有资金注入，但一旦危机过去，资源就会蒸发。从20世纪80年代里根时代开始，这种趋势更是加速了。是的。在社会安全网受到侵蚀这方面，里根是许多事情的起点。是的。对于许多机构来说，这是一个熟悉的故事。是的。你知道，这是故事中复杂的一部分，我们不会深入探讨。
But to simplify, public health agencies saw their budgets get cut decade after decade all the way into the 2000s. The CDC's budget dropped overall from 2010 to 2019. Over the same time period, local public health departments lost more than 50,000 jobs due to funding cuts. And we also saw a ton of privatization during this time. So the hiring of private contractors to do what the government used to do. And so this was the underfunded and very complicated system that Robinson Meyer and Alexis Madrigal encountered And so this was the underfunded and very complicated system
但简单来说，公共卫生机构的预算在几十年里不断被削减，一直持续到21世纪。从2010年到2019年，疾控中心的整体预算下降了。在同一时期，由于资金削减，地方公共卫生部门失去了超过5万个工作岗位。在此期间，我们还看到了大量的私有化。也就是雇佣私人承包商来做以前由政府做的事情资金。因此，这就是罗滨逊·迈耶和亚历克西斯·马德里加尔遇到时的那个资金不足且非常复杂的系统。因此，这就是那个资金不足且非常复杂的系统
that Robinson Meyer and Alexis Madrigal encountered when they set out to gather their own COVID-related data at the start of the pandemic. Here's Alexis. The federal government itself like doesn't actually have the people to do the things that other governments do because we just decided from Reagan onwards that we were essentially
罗滨逊·迈耶和亚历克西斯·马德里加尔在大流行刚开始时着手收集自己的新冠相关数据时遇到了它。这是亚历克西斯。联邦政府本身其实并没有人员来做其他政府所做的事情，因为从里根时代起，我们就决定了，基本上
going to take out state capacity and instead pay consulting fees and contracts to companies because I guess somehow that's like less government years or something. And I imagine all of this makes data gathering and sharing really tough. Yeah, it's kind of hard to imagine a system worse than this one when it comes to data sharing. All these entities report data on what's happening locally, often a little bit differently, using different systems and data conventions. You just have so many reporting entities and officials and jurisdictions, and it's not just
我们要取消国家能力，转而向公司支付咨询费和合同费用，因为我想不知何故这就像是减少了政府干预之类的。我能想象所有这些使得数据收集和共享变得非常艰难。是的，说到数据共享，很难想象比这个更糟糕的系统了。所有这些实体都在报告关于地方情况的数据，通常方式略有不同，使用不同的系统和数据惯例。你拥有太多的报告实体、官员和管辖区，这不仅是因为我们是一个大国家。
because we're a large country. It's also because we have built these data systems over time in this kind of sedimentary pile. And it's very difficult to change them when it's not a crisis. You know, like it's just hard. And so did Alexis and Rob like fully understand the complexities of the health system
这也是因为我们随着时间推移，以这种沉积层的方式构建了这些数据系统。而在非危机时期，要改变它们是非常困难的。你知道，就像这太难了。那么亚历克西斯和罗布在开始收集这些全国性的新冠统计数据时，是否充分理解了卫生系统的复杂性？并没有。就像他们只知道政府没有发布太多关于正在发生的事情的信息。因此，他们开始了他们自己的DIY工作，并招募志愿者来帮忙。
when they started to gather these nationwide statistics about COVID. Not really. Like they just knew that the government wasn't releasing much information about what was going on. And so they started their own DIY efforts and recruited volunteers to help with it. And it turned out I was literally the first person to fill out the volunteer form. Erin Kassane has worked on a bunch of web-focused projects over the years, most recently as an editor and director of content with Night Mozilla Open News. And she had been following COVID really closely and just jumped right into the data gathering.
结果证明，我 literalmente（注：原文如此，即literally）是第一个填写志愿者表格的人。埃琳·卡萨内（Erin Kassane）这些年来参与了许多以网络为重点的项目，最近的一次是担任Night Mozilla Open News的编辑和内容总监。她一直非常密切地关注新冠疫情，并直接投身于数据收集工作。
And the work immediately was just things like, hey, can someone set us up a website? And at the same time, like, how do we open up this spreadsheet and get it to hold up with 20 people going and collecting data and what kind of quality process this should be set up? Because we obviously need to have people double checking these numbers. So it was sort of everything all at once. This group came to be known as the COVID tracking project. And full disclosure, the COVID tracking project received funding from the Robert Wood Johnson
这项工作立刻就变成了诸如“嘿，谁能帮我们建个网站？”之类的事情。与此同时，“我们如何打开这个电子表格，让它能容纳20个人同时去收集数据，并且应该建立什么样的质量流程？”因为我们显然需要有人仔细检查这些数字。所以这一切都是同时发生的。这个群体后来被称为“新冠追踪项目”（COVID Tracking Project）。顺便完全坦白一下，“新冠追踪项目”获得了罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会的资助，
Foundation, which also funded this story. Within a few weeks, the COVID tracking project had several hundred volunteers helping out. There were students, there were people from tech, people from medicine, journalists. And so what exactly did the work they were doing look like? Like how do you begin to gather it? Well, this was very simple and very complicated at the same time. Every day they would reach out to every state and territory in the US to find out how many tests they'd done and numbers of positive cases, hospitalizations, and deaths. And they used a range of methods to get those numbers. They watched a ton of press conferences, for example.
该基金会也资助了这个故事。在几周内，“新冠追踪项目”就有几百名志愿者加入帮忙。有学生，有来自科技界的人，来自医学界的人，还有记者。那么他们所做的工作到底是什么样的？你如何开始收集数据？嗯，这既非常简单又非常复杂。每天他们都会联系美国的所有州和领地，以了解他们做了多少检测，以及阳性病例、住院人数和死亡人数。他们用了一系列方法来获取这些数字。例如，他们观看了大量的记者招待会。
And they would also scrape numbers from state websites. Then they'd put everything into a spreadsheet. And then like once a day, you sort of commit those numbers and you're like, okay, those are the days numbers. And it is easy to do one time. And it's easy to even do, you know, 20 times. But as time went on, it started to get much harder because they began to understand
他们还会从各州的网站上抓取数字。然后他们把所有东西放进一个电子表格里。然后差不多一天一次，你提交这些数字，然后你会说：“好吧，这就是当天的数字。”做一次很容易。甚至做20次也很容易。但随着时间的推移，事情变得困难得多，因为他们开始理解
the idiosyncrasies of the system and also of the data itself. For instance, take the most basic unit of this data, a case of COVID. Like I would think that would be pretty easy to define and count, right? Yeah, yeah, totally. Well, it is not.
这个系统的特质，以及数据本身的特质。例如，以该数据中最基础的单位——一个新冠病例为例。我觉得这应该很容易定义和计算，对吧？是的，是的，完全是。嗯，其实并不是。
We had to sort of figure out over time that a case is not a case. In some places, a case is a confirmed case. In some places, it's confirmed in what's called probable cases. Well, what are those? Okay, here's the definitions. Is this state combining confirmed in probable cases? We can't tell.
随着时间的推移，我们不得不弄清楚，一个病例并不是一个病例。在某些地方，一个病例是确诊病例。在某些地方，它是确诊病例加上所谓的疑似病例。嗯，那是什么？好吧，定义是这样的：这个州是将确诊病例和疑似病例合并了吗？我们看不出来。
Let's call the state. Oh my God. This is making my head hurt just thinking about it. I know, and this was true for most of the metrics they were trying to track. There were all of these different ways that what the states were sending to the federal government was just slightly different. You had different data definitions, you used different systems, and no one really had any idea of how to standardize those things, particularly in the midst of a crisis like
给这个州打电话。哦，天哪。光是想想这事就让我头疼。我知道，对于他们试图追踪的大多数指标来说都是如此。所有这些不同的方式，导致州政府发送给联邦政府的数据只是略有不同。你有不同的数据定义，使用不同的系统，而且没有人真正知道如何标准化这些事情，特别是在像
this. And there are just so many examples of how our COVID data was unstandardized or incomplete. Like another example, did you know that a lot of our local health departments are still at the mercy of facts machines? Oh my god. What can against him surprise? I'm still a Paul. Yeah.
这样一场危机之中。而且有太多的例子表明我们的新冠数据是未标准化的或不完整的。就像另一个例子，你知道我们的许多地方卫生部门仍然受制于传真机吗？哦，天哪。怎么能对它感到惊讶？我仍然感到震惊。是的。
It caused all kinds of problems. Like some states only reported electronically submitted lab results, others combined electronic submissions and faxed submissions. But because people had to enter the faxed information to their tallies manually, there would be these big distortions in the data where all of a sudden, a backlog of faxed results would just be dumped into the numbers all at once.
这导致了各种各样的问题。比如一些州只报告电子提交的实验室结果，其他州则结合了电子提交和传真提交。但由于人们必须将传真信息手动输入到他们的统计中，数据中就会出现这种巨大的扭曲，即突然之间，积压的传真结果会被一次性全部倾倒进数字中。
Right. You hold all the facts once to the end and then you enter them and then all of a sudden the numbers leap. And it makes people mistrust data is what it does. Or here's another example. When there would be a bad surge somewhere and lots of deaths, the people who fill out death certificates would get really behind. And so death numbers would lag. death certificates would get really behind. And so death numbers would lag. Or, yet another example, really critical demographic data would just be missing. There really were whole areas, especially race and ethnicity, where most states and territories never developed a really robust way to collect that kind of demographic data. And when they did, it wasn't standardized.
没错。你把所有的传真都保留到最后，然后你输入它们，突然之间数字就暴涨了。这使得人们对数据产生不信任，这就是它所造成的。或者这里还有另一个例子。当某个地方出现糟糕的激增并有大量死亡时，填写死亡证明的人就会严重落后。因此死亡数字会滞后。死亡证明会严重落后。因此死亡数字会滞后。或者，还有另一个例子，真正关键的人口统计数据会直接缺失。确实存在整个领域，尤其是种族和族裔，大多数州和领地从未开发出真正稳健的方式来收集那种人口统计数据。即使他们这样做了，也没有标准化。
Which of course meant it was hard to tell who was being most impacted by the disease. And this stuff can feel kind of dry, like ultimately we're talking about spreadsheets and data standardization. But there was stuff going on at this time, early in the pandemic, where really good data could have helped. But these N95 respirator masks in particular are in high demand and short supply. I mean, for example,
这当然意味着很难看出谁受该疾病的影响最大。这些东西可能会让人觉得有点枯燥，最终我们谈论的是电子表格和数据标准化。但在大流行初期的这个时候，正在发生一些事情，如果当时有真正好的数据本可以有所帮助。但这些N95呼吸器口罩尤其需求量大且供应短缺。我的意思是，例如，
there was a massive shortage of protective gear for healthcare workers. But still, I have spoken to healthcare workers in San Francisco, Oakland and San Jose today, all who say the shortage of supplies in their hospitals is a problem. If we had had the hospitalization data, knowing who had PPE, who had access to medications, who had staffing shortages, the federal government can, in fact, step in and help with that stuff.
医护人员的防护装备严重短缺。不过，今天我还是同旧金山、奥克兰和圣何塞的医护人员交谈过，他们都说医院里的物资短缺是个问题。如果我们有住院数据，知道谁有个人防护装备（PPE），谁能获得药物，谁有人手短缺，联邦政府实际上就可以介入并提供帮助。
Instead, that became this weird, crazy scramble that benefited nobody, as far as I can tell. So was the U.S. government doing this type of data collection from the states and just not reporting it, or were they just not doing it at all? Well, in those early days, the people at the COVID tracking project certainly thought that the government had its own comprehensive numbers. They thought that someone somewhere within the vast CDC bureaucracy had stats, and you know, better stats than they did. I think all of us really thought that the data did exist,
相反，这变成了一场奇怪的、疯狂的争夺战，据我所能看到的，这对任何人都没有好处。所以美国政府当时是在从各州收集这类数据却只是不报告，还是根本就没收集？嗯，在早期，新冠追踪项目的人当然认为政府有自己的综合数字。他们认为庞大的疾控中心官僚机构中的某个人在某处掌握着统计数据，而且你知道，比他们掌握的统计数据更好。我想我们所有人真的都认为数据是存在的，
and we just couldn't see it. So the work that we were all doing was a stopgap. And presumably, we would need to do it for a little while until the federal government released the numbers they had. But then they started noticing some weird coincidences. So this would have been in March and April 2020. And back then, there were these press conferences that Vice President Mike Pence was doing. Thank you, Mr. President. And let me echo your words about all the dedicated men and women on the White House coronavirus task force.
只是我们看不到。所以我们所有人做的工作只是一种权宜之计。据推测，我们需要做一段时间，直到联邦政府发布他们掌握的数字。但随后他们开始注意到一些奇怪的巧合。所以这应该发生在2020年3月和4月。当时副总统迈克·彭斯正在举行这些记者招待会。谢谢你，总统先生。我要呼应你对白宫冠状病毒工作组中所有敬业的男男女女的评价。
And the COVID tracking people would watch those press conferences to see what kind of numbers the government shared and how they compared to the numbers that they were gathering. It was reported to us that at this moment more than 746,000 Americans have tested positive for the coronavirus. Unfortunately, more than 68,000 Americans have fully recovered, but sadly, more than 41,000 Americans have lost their lives to the coronavirus uh... and we were like hey you know his numbers really close to ours we must be
新冠追踪项目的人会观看这些记者招待会，看看政府分享了什么样的数字，以及它们与他们正在收集的数字相比如何。据我们汇报，此时已有超过746,000名美国人确诊感染了冠状病毒。不幸的是，超过68,000名美国人已经完全康复，但令人悲伤的是，超过41,000名美国人因冠状病毒失去了生命……然后我们当时想，嘿，你知道他的数字跟我们的非常接近，我们一定
doing a good job because he's getting those federal numbers clearly and you know here we are just scraping from public data despite the fact that there have been more than eight hundred forty three thousand americans a contract the coronavirus and we grieve the from public data. Despite the fact that there have been more than 843,000 Americans of contract to the coronavirus and we grieve the loss of more than 47,000 of our countrymen. And then we realized they were tracking really closely and I think a
做得很好，因为他显然在获取那些联邦数字，你知道的，而我们在这里只是从公共数据中抓取。尽管事实上已有超过843,000名美国人感染了冠状病毒，我们为失去47,000多名同胞而悲痛。从公共数据中抓取。尽管事实上已有超过843,000名美国人感染了冠状病毒，我们为失去47,000多名同胞而悲痛。然后我们意识到他们的追踪结果非常接近，我想我们中的一些人在那个时候开始怀疑他实际上只是在读我们的数字，只是四舍五入了一下。哇。哇。好吧。
few of us started to suspect at that point that he was actually reading our numbers just rounded. Wow. Wow. Okay. And then their suspicions were later confirmed when the Trump administration published a report that clearly used the project's data and charts and cited them in the footnotes. And it was like, oh, they're just looking at our site. Like, we are the process. We are the process. We are the ones who are making this data. We were waiting for the cavalry, and then it turned out,
后来，当特朗普政府发布了一份明显使用了该项目的数据和图表并在脚注中引用它们的报告时，他们的怀疑得到了证实。当时的感觉就像是，“哦，他们只是在看我们的网站。我们就是这个流程。我们就是这个流程。我们才是制造这些数据的人。”我们在等待骑兵，结果证明，
like, we were the cavalry, and we were like, no, no, no. We don't even have horses. We can't be the cavalry. And it's kind of darkly funny, but it is also scary. You know, you kind of think sometimes, like, well, you know, if disaster X were to happen, well, you know, if disaster X were to happen, well, you know, somebody's thinking about that. You know what I mean?
就像，我们就是骑兵，然后我们当时想，不，不，不。我们甚至连马都没有。我们不可能是骑兵。这有点黑色幽默，但也很吓人。你知道，你有时会想，嗯，如果灾难X发生了，嗯，你知道，如果灾难X发生了，嗯，你知道的，会有人考虑这事的。你知道我的意思吗？
Like, well, somebody's gonna do that. And the truth is, no, nobody's gonna f**king do it sometimes. We were not ready. We did not have a system in place. And so I can imagine them feeling panic about like, oh my God, okay. So we thought we were just messing around.
就像，总会有人去做的。但事实是，不，有时候根本没有人他妈的去做。我们没有准备好。我们没有建立一个系统。所以我想象他们当时会感到恐慌，比如“哦，天哪，好吧。我们以为我们只是在瞎胡闹。”
We're doing our best. And we thought that the government was going to save us and they turned out they're not. But what was part of them kind of proud that the government was using their numbers? I don't think so. No. Okay. Like, I'm not sure how everyone on the project felt, but at least some of them were pretty shaken by this realization, like Aaron.
我们在尽力而为。我们以为政府会拯救我们，结果证明他们并没有。但他们当中是否有一部分人因为政府在用他们的数字而感到有点骄傲？我不觉得。没有。好吧。就像，我不确定项目中每个人的感受，但至少其中一些人被这一发现震惊了，比如埃琳。
That's an immensely stressful position to be in for a bunch of volunteers because on one hand, yeah, it's great that our numbers are actually really useful. And on the other hand, are you kidding me? That's the best you can do with the entire resources of the federal government is get the data that we make every day by looking at websites.
对于一群志愿者来说，这是一个极其有压力的位置，因为一方面，是的，我们的数字实际上非常有用，这很棒；但另一方面，你在开玩笑吗？利用整个联邦政府的资源，你能做到的最好结果就是获取我们每天通过浏览网站制造的数据？
I mean, it's really hard for me to understand at this point, like what was going on at the CDC? Like what is going on within the agency at this time? Well, I'll start by saying that we came into the pandemic with data systems that just were not designed to gather and process the kind of fast, high-resolution data that people wanted. Like the demand for data just went way beyond
我的意思是，此时我真的很难理解，疾控中心当时到底在发生什么？当时该机构内部到底发生了什么？嗯，我首先要说的是，我们进入这场大流行时所拥有的数据系统，根本不是为了收集和处理人们想要的快速、高分辨率数据而设计的。就像对数据的需求远远超出了
what public health officials had ever encountered before and they were caught flat-footed. There was also the general organizational chaos of the Trump administration, which certainly didn't help. But there were a number of ways the CDC tried to compensate. So as an example, in April 2020, the agency started working on a new electronic reporting system that would collect detailed testing data from every state. It took a long time to get all the states onboarded to that system, like more than a year.
公共卫生官员以前遇到过的任何情况，他们被打了个措手不及。特朗普政府普遍存在的组织混乱也肯定没有帮到忙。但疾控中心尝试了多种方法进行弥补。例如，在2020年4月，该机构开始着手开发一个新的电子报告系统，用于收集来自每个州的详细检测数据。让所有州都加入该系统花费了很长时间，超过了一年。
As that was happening, the agency was also using some of its existing surveillance systems and methods to track this new disease. Finally, CDC quietly launched a new website. It's, you go to, so for example, this is another press conference held by the coronavirus task force in early April, where they talk about data that the CDC has started to release. This surveillance data is bringing together our influenza-like illnesses with their syndromic management databases so that you can track- And just to parse that for you. Yeah, that would be helpful.
在此期间，该机构还利用其现有的部分监测系统和方法来追踪这种新疾病。最后，疾控中心悄悄推出了一个新网站。也就是，你去访问，例如，这是冠状病毒工作组在4月初举行的另一场记者招待会，他们在会上谈到了疾控中心开始发布的的数据。这些监测数据将我们的流感样疾病与他们的综合征管理数据库结合起来，以便你可以追踪——为了给你剖析一下。是的，那会很有帮助。
So what they were doing is that the agency had adapted a couple of their existing systems for this new task of tracking COVID. Their system that tracks unusual levels of disease in places like emergency rooms and urgent care centers. That's the syndromeic surveillance data. And they're flu reporting systems. And the way that the CDC tracks flu is that they sample the population
所以他们所做的是，该机构调整了他们现有的几个系统，以适应追踪新冠这项新任务。他们追踪急诊室和 urgent care 中心等地方异常疾病水平的系统。那就是综合征监测数据。还有他们的流感报告系统。疾控中心追踪流感的方式是，他们对人口进行抽样，
and then model a broader picture. So the data isn't comprehensive. And there are definitely some reasons for using the older system. For one thing, the states were already used to it. The United States, the states are used to using this system. It's in emergency rooms, it's in hospitals, it's in doctors' offices, and it gives you insight and you can see very clearly.
然后模拟出更广泛的画面。所以数据并不是全面的。使用旧系统确实有一些原因。一方面，各州已经习惯了它。美国，各州都习惯于使用这个系统。它存在于急诊室、医院、医生的办公室里，它能为你提供洞察，你可以看得非常清楚。
But the fact was these existing systems just weren't working that well. The agency was struggling to keep track of testing and case rates across the country. It was struggling to update hospital data, which includes really critical stuff like bed availability and ventilator supply. And with the hospital data, this is like a whole other story.
但事实是，这些现有的系统就是运作得不是那么好。该机构一直在努力追踪全国各地的检测和病例感染率。它一直在努力更新医院数据，其中包括非常关键的东西，比如床位可用性和呼吸机供应。关于医院数据，这是另一个完整的故事。
But the CDC was moving so slowly that eventually the agency that oversees them, HHS, just took over gathering those stats and built a much better and faster system. But the CDC still seems to be at the center of all this today. So does that mean that they eventually started gathering their stats themselves in a different way or updated their systems? Yeah, they eventually pivoted, but it took months before they started aggregating and sharing more of their own data. So they released their own data tracker in early May,
但疾控中心的行动太慢了，以至于最终监督他们的机构——卫生与公众服务部（HHS）直接接管了这些统计数据的收集，并构建了一个更好、更快的系统。但疾控中心今天似乎仍然处于这一切的中心。所以这是否意味着他们最终以不同的方式开始自己收集统计数据，或者更新了他们的系统？是的，他们最终进行了调整，但在他们开始聚合和分享更多他们自己的数据之前，花了几个月的时间。因此他们在5月初发布了他们自己的数据追踪器，
which was 15 weeks after the first reported case of COVID in the US, and more than eight weeks after the launch of the COVID tracking project. And even when they did that, they're continued to be problems with the data and big discrepancies between their testing numbers and state numbers. And is there a sense of why it would take so long? I mean like a few enterprises and journalists and a bunch of volunteers had something very quickly.
这距离美国报道首例新冠病例有15周之久，距离“新冠追踪项目”启动有8周多。即便如此，数据仍然存在问题，他们的数字与各州的数字之间存在巨大差异。有没有人知道为什么会花这么长时间？我的意思是，几个企业、记者和一群志愿者非常快就搞出了一些东西。
Why do you think it took the CDC so long? Well, I have reached out to the CDC a number of times to try and get their take on all this and they haven't responded. But I think a lot of times to try and get their take on all this, and they haven't responded. But I think a lot of critics of the CDC think there is something in the structure and culture of the agency that keeps them from moving fast and breaking protocol in an emergency. You know, I think there was an attitude among a lot of people in the CDC about not overreacting to COVID, basically like, oh, well, you know, if we design all these systems around the disease de jour, they're even have like a comment like this on the CDC's data modernization
你认为为什么疾控中心花了这么长时间？嗯，我曾多次联系疾控中心，试图了解他们对这一切的看法，但他们没有回应。但我认为，疾控中心的很多批评者认为，该机构的结构和文化中存在某种东西，使他们在紧急情况下无法迅速行动并打破常规。你知道，我认为疾控中心很多人的态度是不要对新冠做出过度反应，基本上就像，哦，好吧，你知道，如果我们围绕当下的某种疾病来设计所有这些系统，他们甚至在疾控中心的数据现代化
page for one of like the conferences they had, you know, basically like quoting someone at the conference saying like, we can't't like over respond to the disease de jour. And I'm like, oh, I'm sorry. Did your other diseases de jures kill 600,000 people? Like, it's closer to a million now. I maybe we should be over reacting to this one. Seems reasonable to design things around this, you know? And I think that was really a big piece of it.
页面上对他们举行的一个会议发表过类似这样的评论，你知道，基本上就像引用会议上某个人的话说，我们不能对当下的疾病做出过度反应。然后我就想，哦，非常抱歉。你们之前当下的那些疾病都杀死了60万人的吗？就像，现在接近一百万了。也许我们应该对这一种做出过度反应。围绕这一点来设计系统似乎是合理的，对吧？我认为这确实是其中的一个重要部分。
It was like they didn't want to custom design systems just for COVID. That was not what CDC wanted to do. But in an unprecedented situation with a new disease we had never encountered before, moving through the population in ways that we were only beginning to understand, we needed new systems and we needed the public health establishment to be as deep in the data as the COVID tracking project was. If you're not in the data every day or every few days, if you don't know how it's constructed,
就像他们不想专门为新冠定制设计系统一样。那不是疾控中心想做的事情。但在一个前所未有的情况下，面对一种我们从未遇到过的新疾病，它在人群中传播的方式我们才刚刚开始理解，我们需要新的系统，我们需要公共卫生机构像新冠追踪项目（COVID Tracking Project）那样深入数据。如果你每天或每隔几天都不接触数据，如果你不知道它是如何构建的，
you don't understand what's actually happening and like where the future hotspots are and the future places to be concerned, and you don't understand what it looks like when a state explodes with cases. So I know the COVID tracking project no longer exists. So how did they make that decision to end the project? Well, you know, about a year into the pandemic as Biden was coming into office, you know, vaccinations were happening, and the pandemic seemed to be on the way. And so that was when they stopped it. And part of it was that it was taking a toll
你就不会明白实际发生了什么，以及未来的热点在哪里、未来需要关注的地方在哪里，你也不会明白当一个州的确诊病例呈爆炸式增长时会是什么样子。所以我知道新冠追踪项目已经不存在了。那么他们是如何做出结束该项目的决定的呢？嗯，你知道，在大流行开始大约一年后，随着拜登就职，你知道，疫苗接种正在进行，大流行似乎正在消退。所以这就是他们停止该项目的时候。部分原因是因为它对
on the people involved. Like they had never intended it to be a long-term project. And even something as mundane as data entry had a high cost. While this was happening, we had family members dying. We had people we knew who were in those statistics. But there was another reason as well, which is that the COVID tracking project founders really thought the government should be responsible for this work. You know, we did not think that the public health data in widest distribution for the United States and the COVID pandemic should come from volunteer labor. And the Biden administration had promised to create a pandemic dashboard, which the COVID
参与其中的人造成了沉重的负担。就像他们从未打算将其长期项目一样。甚至连数据录制这样平凡的事情也付出了高昂的代价。正当这一切发生时，我们的家庭成员却在死去。我们认识的人就出现在那些统计数据中。但还有另一个原因，那就是新冠追踪项目的创立者们真的认为政府应该对这项工作负责。你知道，我们不认为美国最大范围分发的公共卫生数据和新冠大流行的数据应该来自志愿劳动力。而拜登政府曾承诺创建一个疫情仪表板，这让新冠
tracking project people were excited about. They even helped advise on a framework for how to do it. But now, more than a year into Biden's term, that still has not materialized. Even though COVID-related data remains both very critical and quite confusing to understand. And you know, what made the COVID tracking project unique as an organization was that they were dedicated to researching and explaining all these various flaws and inconsistencies in the data.
追踪项目的人感到兴奋。他们甚至协助就如何做到这一点提供了一个框架的建议。但现在，在拜登任期一年多后，这仍然没有实现。尽管与新冠相关的数据仍然非常关键且相当令人费解。你知道，新冠追踪项目作为一个独特的组织，其独特之处在于他们致力于研究和解释数据中的所有这些各种缺陷和不一致之处。
There were other data trackers and other volunteer data groups, but it was the COVID tracking project that was really dedicated to that kind of analysis, which we still badly need. Data can't talk. Data can't explain itself, particularly when you're speaking either to, you know, this idea of a general public, but also to reporters, to anybody in media, to people, even in government agencies, the data has to be contextualized and explained, and that's still largely not happening. I should say, all the folks I spoke with at the COVID tracking project recognize that there are
还有其他的数据追踪器和其他的志愿者数据小组，但正是新冠追踪项目真正致力于那种分析，而我们现在依然非常需要这种分析。数据不会说话。数据无法解释自己，特别是当你既在对公众说这些，也在对记者、媒体中的任何人、甚至是政府机构中的人说时，数据必须被置于语境中并加以解释，而这在很大程度上仍然没有发生。我应该说，我在新冠追踪项目交谈过的所有人，都认识到
some things the CDC does really, really well. There are incredible scientists at CDC and NIH doing this remarkable world-changing work on vaccines and all these other things. And the CDC did have some successes with data as well. You know, the electronic lab reporting system, the agency help build, has apparently really increased the speed and accuracy of state data coming into the agency. But we're still nowhere near having the kind of surveillance systems we'll need. The next time a pandemic happens.
疾控中心确实有一些做得非常非常好的事情。疾控中心和美国国立卫生研究院（NIH）有杰出的科学家在疫苗和所有这些其他事情上做着这种卓越的、改变世界的工作。而且疾控中心在数据方面也取得了一些成功。你知道，该机构帮助建立的电子实验室报告系统，显然确实提高了流入该机构的各州数据的速度和准确性。但我们距离拥有下一次大流行时所需的监视系统，仍然相去甚远。
If you talk to pandemic people, you know, like this was like a starter pandemic. I mean, it just could have been so much worse and it will be so much worse. You know, we know we are going to face worse threats. And the thing that I have never seen is any real reckoning in the federal government with what we didn't do, with the failures to build a real surveillance system. What did you do to make your life a better place? While I was working on this story, I ended up thinking a lot about this thing
如果你跟研究大流行的人谈论，你知道，这就好比是一场入门级的大流行。我的意思是，情况本可能糟糕得多，而且将来也会糟糕得多。你知道，我们知道我们将面临更严重的威胁。而我从未见过的是，联邦政府对我们没有做的事情、对未能建立真正的监视系统进行了任何真正的反思。你做了什么来让你的生活变得更好？在我撰写这篇报道时，我最终一直在思考斯蒂芬·约翰逊（Stephen Johnson）
that Stephen Johnson told me. He was one of the historians of public health. I asked him if he had followed the work of the COVID tracking project and what he made of it. I had two reactions in a way to the COVID data project, which was on the one hand, it seemed scandalous that they had to do the work that they had to do that that should have already been
对我说过的话。他是公共卫生历史学家之一。我问他是否关注过新冠追踪项目的工作，以及他是如何看待它的。在某种程度上，我对新冠数据项目有两种反应，一方面，他们不得不做他们不得不做的工作，这似乎是一桩丑闻，因为这些工作本应该已经
underway. Yeah, that makes sense. That's my reaction, too. Yeah. But two was, there was part of me that was like, okay, these are the airs to John Grant. The amateur data collector who does it because they perceive something is missing in the system and There's not a lot of time to lose and they need to get in there and fill in this missing piece
在进行了。是的，这说得通。这也是我的反应。是的。但另一方面，我内心的一部分感觉是，好吧，这些是约翰·格兰特（John Grant）的传人。业余数据收集者，他们这样做是因为他们察觉到系统里缺少了某些东西，而且时间紧迫，他们需要介入并填补这一缺失的部分
That's a beautiful Tradition in the history of health and so it was part of me was kind of moved to see it kick into gear. I mean, I get that. I love that story, and I'm struck by the fact that John Grant is a romantic figure of a person like jumping in and filling in a need, in inventing whole new fields of science at the same time. But, you know, the story of the COVID tracking project, I'm really impressed by the people who did it, but it doesn't seem like a romantic story at all. Like, it really feels like a tragedy to me.
这是健康史上的一个美丽传统，所以我有部分内心被看到它运转起来所感动。我的意思是，我理解。我喜欢这个故事，并且我印象深刻的是，约翰·格兰特是一个浪漫的人物，像一个跳出来填补需求、同时发明全新科学领域的人。但是，你知道，新冠追踪项目的故事，我对那些做这件事的人印象深刻，但它一点也不像一个浪漫的故事。相反，它真的让我觉得像是一个悲剧。
Mm-hmm. Yeah, I think it is a tragedy. Like, we shouldn't have to John Grant the pandemic. Not after hundreds of years of public health developments. Yeah, I mean, what we really want is a boring story where a bureaucracy just does its job. Yeah, competent bureaucrats. Yeah, here's to the competent bureaucrats.
嗯哼。是的，我认为这是一个悲剧。就像，我们本不该在经历了数百年的公共卫生发展后，还要用“约翰·格兰特”的方式去应对大流行。是的，我的意思是，我们真正想要的是一个无聊的故事，即官僚机构只是在做好它的本职工作。是的，称职的官僚。是的，向称职的官僚致敬。
Coming up next, we'll talk about some potential fixes for our public health data systems. We'll hear from a former CDC director and someone who has thought a lot about who gets erased from our current data and how to make it better. Stay with us. Support for this four-part series exploring the future of health and wellbeing comes from the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation, which is committed to improving health and health equity in the United States.
接下来，我们将讨论修复公共卫生数据系统的潜在方法。我们将听到一位前疾控中心主任的发言，以及一位深入思考过谁被我们当前的数据抹去以及如何改进数据的人的见解。请继续收听。本系列共有四集，旨在探讨健康与福祉的未来，其资金支持来自罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会（Robert Wood Johnson Foundation），该基金会致力于改善美国的健康和健康公平。
Knowing that the healthy, equitable future we all deserve won't simply arrive, RWJF is exploring how new technologies, scientific discoveries, cultural shifts, and unforeseen events like those in today's story may shape our lives in years to come. Through these explorations, they're learning what it will take to build a future that provides every individual with a fair and just opportunity to thrive no matter who they are, where they live, or how much money they make. Learn more about their efforts at rwjf.org.
深知我们应得的健康、公平的未来不会凭空降临，罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会正在探索新科技、科学发现、文化转变以及像今天故事中那样无法预见的事件，将如何在未来几年塑造我们的生活。通过这些探索，他们正在了解需要什么来建立一个未来，为每个人提供公平公正的繁荣机会，无论他们是谁、住在哪里或赚多少钱。在 rwjf.org 上了解更多关于他们的努力。
If you like thinking about the future of things and have a hundred about the future, share it at shareyourhf.org. And if you like thinking about the future of things and have a hunch about the future, share it at shareyourhunch.org. I'm going there now. Okay, I'm selecting the prompt, I have a hunch. I have a hunch that the increasing misery of air travel will cause people to reconsider train travel in the US and it will be more popular than it has been for decades. Check out other hunches and share your own hunch
如果你喜欢思考事物的未来，并且对未来有某种直觉，请在 shareyourhf.org 上分享它。如果你喜欢思考事物的未来，并且对未来有某种直觉，请在 shareyourhunch.org 上分享它。我现在就要去了。好的，我正在选择提示，我有一种直觉。我有一种直觉，那就是航空旅行日益增加的痛苦将导致人们重新考虑美国的火车旅行，它将比几十年来更受欢迎。在 shareyourhunch.org
at shareyourhunch.org. All right, I'm back with Delaney Hall and we're gonna be talking about how to fix our public health surveillance systems, which that sounds really ominous when I say it that way but that's really what we're trying to fix. Yeah, this is the good kind of surveillance systems. This is the surveillance that we want.
上查看其他人的直觉并分享你自己的直觉。好了，我回到了德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）身边，我们将讨论如何修复我们的公共卫生监视系统，我这样说听起来真的很不祥，但这确实是我们试图修复的目标。是的，这是那种好的监视系统。这是我们想要的监视。
So how do we fix them? I guess, spoiler alert, I don't think there is one clear answer to that massive problem. Yeah, I can't say I'm surprised to hear that. But I did speak with people during my reporting who had a range of interesting ideas about how to make things work better, both within the system and with data
那么我们如何修复它们呢？我想，剧透一下，我认为对于这个巨大问题并没有一个明确的答案。是的，我不能说听到这个我感到惊讶。但在我的采访过程中，我确实与一些人交谈过，他们对如何让事情运作得更好有一系列有趣的想法，无论是在系统内部还是在数据方面，
in particular, and especially with race and ethnicity data, which represents one of the biggest failures in our current system. Oh, that's really interesting. Okay. So tell me more about that. So I will get to the race and ethnicity data a little bit later. I wanted to start with one immediate fix that came up in conversation with Alexis Madrigal of the COVID tracking project. And he said it really would have helped if the federal government had just been extremely clear with states about what information they wanted reported and how. Because then the data coming from the states would have been more standardized and easier to compare and analyze.
特别是种族和族裔数据，这代表了我们当前系统中的最大失败之一。哦，这真的很有趣。好的。那么告诉我更多关于这方面的信息。所以我会稍后谈到种族和族裔数据。我想从与新冠追踪项目的亚历克斯·马德里加尔（Alexis Madrigal）交谈时提出的一个直接修复方案开始。他说，如果联邦政府能够非常明确地向各州说明他们希望报告什么信息以及如何报告，那将真的很有帮助。因为这样来自各州的数据就会更加标准化，更容易进行比较和分析。
Probably the thing that would have made the biggest single difference on a data level would be if the federal government had said basically on an ultra, ultra, ultra precise level is what we need. Like we need it to come like from this system and answer all those small questions. And this was actually something that the COVID tracking project ended up doing in the absence of really clear guidance from the government.
可能在数据层面上产生最大单一影响的事情是，如果联邦政府基本上在超级、超级、超级精确的水平上说，这就是我们需要的东西。比如我们需要它来自这个系统并回答所有这些小问题。而在政府缺乏真正明确指导的情况下，这实际上是新冠追踪项目最终做的事情。
They pulled together their own guidelines and distributed them to the states. Oh, that's interesting, but I'm guessing that if that guidance was coming straight from the government, it would probably be more successful. Yeah, totally. I mean, the government, believe it or not, has more authority than a volunteer effort, however impressive that effort was. The other thing is, even if the government had been really clear about how it wanted the data reported,
他们汇集了自己的指南并将其分发给各州。哦，这很有趣，但我猜如果这些指导直接来自政府，可能会更成功。是的，完全如此。我的意思是，信不信由你，政府拥有比志愿者工作更大的权威，无论这种工作多么令人印象深刻。另一件事是，即使政府对其希望如何报告数据非常明确，
that would have made things better for sure. But it wouldn't have solved the underlying issues with the surveillance system. Those are much bigger and more complex. You can't fix the data system without fixing the broader public health system. This is Dr. Thomas Frieden. He was the director of the CDC from 2009 to 2017. He also worked as the health commissioner for New York City for seven years. And he testified before Congress in March 2021.
那肯定会让事情变得更好。但这并没有解决监视系统的根本问题。那些问题要大得多、复杂得多。不修复更广泛的公共卫生系统，你就无法修复数据系统。这位是托马斯·弗里登（Thomas Frieden）博士。他在2009年至2017年期间担任疾控中心主任。他还担任过七年纽约市卫生专员。他在2021年3月向国会作证。
So this was around the time the COVID tracking project shut down. And he said in that testimony that, quote, lack of accurate real time information was one of the greatest failures of the US response to the COVID-19 pandemic. Wow. Okay. That's definitive. Yeah. I mean, he said that our data systems are broken basically from the top to the bottom. And he said that it is not just the CDC's fault here. So I think saying, well, CDC couldn't get the data together, CDC was dealing with local and state health departments that were overwhelmed and couldn't collect the data,
所以这大约是在新冠追踪项目关闭的时候。他在那次证词中表示，“缺乏准确的实时信息是美国应对新冠肺炎大流行反应的最大失败之一。”哇。好的。这很明确。是的。我的意思是，他表示我们的数据系统基本上从上到下都崩溃了。而且他说这不仅仅是疾控中心的错。所以我认为，说什么“疾控中心无法将数据汇集在一起”，是因为疾控中心当时正在应对不堪重负且无法收集数据的本地和州卫生部门，
hospitals that didn't have standardized data, and laboratory testing that was insufficient and the contact tracing system that never really worked effectively in most places. Wow, I mean, that is a wide range of failures. I mean, I imagine this all goes back to both the fractured nature of our public health system and the way the states and the federal government really don't work hand in hand when it comes to these things. And then we also talked about the hauling out of these institutions and systems that has been going on for decades, really.
没有标准化数据的医院，以及不充分的实验室检测和在大多数地方从未真正有效运作的接触者追踪系统。哇，我的意思是，这是一系列广泛的失败。我的意思是，我猜这一切都归结为我们公共卫生系统的破碎性，以及各州和联邦政府在涉及这些事情时真的没有携手合作的方式。然后我们还讨论了这些机构和系统数十年来一直在被掏空的情况。
Right. Our system got to this very bad point, thanks to underfunding it for decades. And we talked about this a little bit in the piece, but we're already seeing the cycle of panic and neglect as it's known, kick in yet again. So a crisis happens, money and resources pour in, the crisis fades and the money goes away. And this is just not a good way to fund a system that needs to rebuild some of its critical infrastructure from the bottom up. You can't build a sustainable system with one-time dollars.
没错。由于数十年来资金不足，我们的系统陷入了这种非常糟糕的境地。我们在节目中稍微讨论了这一点，但我们已经再次看到被称为“恐慌与忽视”的循环在上演。因此，危机发生时，资金和资源倾注而入；危机消退时，资金随之消失。这绝对不是资助一个需要从头开始重建部分关键基础设施的系统的好方法。你不能用一次性资金建立一个可持续的系统。
And he really wants to see us build that sustainable system. He knows everyone in public health knows that this kind of real-time data collection is important. But Dr. Frieden says it's going to take years of investment to fix it. There needs to be an agreement about a national architecture for data gathering and sharing. The government needs to be able to hire really talented programmers.
他真的很希望看到我们建立那个可持续的系统。他知道，公共卫生领域的每个人都知道这种实时数据收集非常重要。但弗里登博士表示，修复它需要多年的投资。需要就数据收集和共享的国家架构达成一致。政府需要能够聘请到真正有才华的程序员。
We need to find workarounds for some very tricky problems, including the fact that we don't have national health identifiers in this country, which means that tracking people across different systems is a big challenge. There's just, there's a lot to sort out. We need a multi-year investment to modernize it. It's not just a matter of replacing fax machines with an electronic secure interchange. But as we also heard in the main story, this is not just about money or technology. Those
我们需要为一些非常棘手的问题找到变通方法，包括我们这个国家没有国家健康标识符的事实，这意味着跨不同系统追踪人员是一个巨大的挑战。有很多事情需要理顺。我们需要多年的投资来进行现代化改造。这不仅仅是用电子安全交换取代传真机的问题。但正如我们在主故事中所听到的，这不仅关乎金钱或技术。这些
things are definitely important. But there are elements of the CDC's current culture and how it interacts with local health departments that also needs to change. Right. So my impression of the CDC is that it's a very scientific and academic organization in terms of its outlook. They do very careful analysis before they release anything or recommend anything, and that's not always what the public demands. Yeah, I think it's safe to say that the agency tends to move slow. It's also freedom-pointed out, sometimes subject to political oversight and vetting that can contribute to that slowness.
事情绝对重要。但疾控中心当前的文化及其与地方卫生部门互动的方式中，也有一些元素需要改变。没错就我而言，我对疾控中心的印象是，从其视角来看，它是一个非常科学和学术的组织。他们在发布任何东西或建议任何东西之前都会进行非常仔细的分析，而这并不总是公众所要求的。是的，我认为可以安全地说，该机构往往行动迟缓。正如弗里登所指出的，有时还要受制于政治监督和审查，这可能会导致这种迟缓。
But for whatever reasons, I think it moves at a different pace than people in local health departments who are frontline responders. They need to move fast, sometimes with just the best data available at that moment. And so freedom thinks there should be more movement sometimes with just the best data available at that moment. And so, Frieden thinks there should be more movement back and forth between the CDC and local
但无论出于何种原因，我认为它的行动步伐与作为一线响应人员的地方卫生部门的人不同。他们需要快速行动，有时只能依靠那一刻获得的最佳数据。因此，弗里登认为，有时应该在疾控中心与地方和州级卫生部门之间进行更多的来回互动，
and state level health departments, so they can understand each other's needs. There are two few people working at CDC headquarters in Atlanta who have worked for two or five or 10 years at a county or city or state or global health department embedded to understand that if you need an answer sometimes it's in the next four or five minutes not in the next four or five hours and certainly not next four or five days. And so what Dr. Frieden has proposed is having thousands of staff on the CDC payroll who are actually
以便他们能够了解彼此的需求。亚特兰大疾控中心总部的工作人员中，有太少的人曾在县、市、州或全球卫生部门嵌入工作过两年、五年或十年，从而无法理解如果你需要一个答案，有时它需要在接下来的四五分钟内，而不是接下来的四五小时，更不用说接下来的四五天了。因此，弗里登博士提出的建议是，让疾控中心薪酬名单上的数千名员工实际上嵌入到县市卫生部门工作几年，然后他们再轮换回疾控中心总部。
embedded in county and city health departments for a few years and who then rotate back to CDC headquarters. That's an interesting suggestion. I mean, are there any indications that the CDC is seriously looking at this or changing its culture in any way? Well, I mean, I have not heard of anything like what Dr. Friedin is proposing, like a cultural exchange between the CDC and local health departments. I also think that the COVID tracking project founders would say there is nothing close
这是一个有趣的建议。我的意思是，有什么迹象表明疾控中心正在认真考虑这一点或以任何方式改变其文化吗？嗯，我的意思是，我没有听说过任何类似于弗里登博士所提出的事情，比如疾控中心与地方卫生部门之间的文化交流。我也认为新冠追踪项目的创立者会说，现在疾控中心正在发生的事情，离他们希望看到的灵魂拷问的程度还差得远。就像对大流行期间出错的事情进行真正的反思一样。但你知道，该机构有一些新的努力。比如，疾控中心内部的一个名为预测与疫情分析中心（CFA）的中心。
to the level of soul searching that they would like to see happening at the CDC right now. Like a real reckoning with what went wrong during the pandemic. But you know, there are some new efforts at the agency. Like for example, a center within the CDC called the Center for Forecasting and Outbreak Analytics, the CFA. Okay. So what's the CFA supposed to do? It's being built as a weather service for disease, a group that can forecast outbreaks, which is interesting and challenging work. And how it relates to data is that the quality of any given model and its resulting forecast
好的。那么CFA要做什么？它被构建为一个疾病的气象服务，一个可以预测疫情的组织，这是一项有趣且具有挑战性的工作。它与数据的关系在于，任何给定模型的质量及其产生的预测很大程度上取决于输入其中的数据的质量。因此，在我们当前的系统中，即使是测试阳性率或住院人数等简单的指标也是含糊不清的，这对大流行建模人员来说将是一个问题。
depends very heavily on the quality of data that goes into it. So in our current system, we're even simple metrics like test positivity rates or hospitalizations are ambiguous, that is going to be a problem for the pandemic modelers. Totally. I mean, if the CFA is going to be successful, they've got to sort out that data stuff from the get go because you can have the greatest model in the world and all these people willing to do it and they could predict amazing things. But if the data is not there, then it does not matter. Yeah, the data stuff has to come first. It's foundational. Yeah. And then finally, there's one other aspect of the data that we should talk about because
完全正确。我的意思是，如果CFA要成功，他们必须从一开始就理顺那些数据方面的事情，因为你可以拥有世界上最好的模型和所有愿意做这件事的人，他们可以预测出惊人的事情。但如果数据不存在，那就没有关系了。是的，数据必须放在首位。这是基础。是的。最后，还有关于数据的另一个方面我们应该讨论，因为它代表了我们当前知识中的一个巨大空白，
it represents a huge gap in our current knowledge. And that is how we collect or rather do not collect data related to race and ethnicity. Like if we're going to be rebuilding our data systems in the way that Friedin is describing, it's worth thinking through this question in particular. Yeah, I remember when I was following the work at the COVID tracking project, like this was an issue that they really focused on. Yeah, it definitely was.
那就是我们如何收集或更确切地说没有收集与种族和族裔相关的数据。就像如果我们要按照弗里登所描述的那样重建我们的数据系统，特别思考这个问题是值得的。是的，我记得当我关注新冠追踪项目的工作时，这真的是他们重点关注的一个问题。是的，绝对是。
The COVID tracking project ended up developing a whole wing of their project devoted specifically to race and ethnicity data. They did that work in collaboration with Dr. Ibrahim X. Kendi, who runs the Boston University Center for Anti-Racist Research. And early in the pandemic, Dr. Kendi wrote a series of essays in the Atlantic where he argued that we really do not know who's being most impacted by COVID-19 because the data around race is just so limited. And so why is that? Is it that race and ethnicity information is just not gathered? Is it just not
新冠追踪项目最终开发了专门致力于种族和族裔数据的整个项目分支。他们与波士顿大学反种族主义研究中心主任伊布拉姆·X·肯迪（Ibrahim X. Kendi）博士合作完成了这项工作。在大流行早期，肯迪博士在《大西洋月刊》上写了一系列文章，他在文中辩称，我们真的不知道谁受新冠肺炎的影响最大，因为围绕种族的数据实在太有限了。那么为什么会这样呢？是因为没有收集种族和族裔信息吗？还是只是没有分享？
shared? Like, what is the breakdown here? The data is insufficient in a number of ways. And to help explain how I'd like to introduce you to Abigail Echo Hawk. We all know somebody. We all know somebody who is impacted by COVID-19. We all know somebody who is impacted by a death even if we weren't ourselves. Echo Hawk is a citizen of the Pawnee Nation of Oklahoma and she's the director of the Urban Indian Health Institute in Seattle, Washington. It's one of 12 tribal epidemiology centers in the country. And Echo Hawk says that it's clear native people were disproportionately affected by COVID, even just anecdotally, like she said.
这里的崩溃点在哪里？数据在许多方面都是不充分的。为了帮助解释这一点，我想向大家介绍阿比盖尔·埃科霍克（Abigail Echo Hawk）。我们都认识某人。我们都认识某个受新冠肺炎影响的人。我们都认识一个受死亡影响的人，即使我们自己没有。埃科霍克是俄克拉何马州波尼族（Pawnee Nation）的公民，她是华盛顿州西雅图城市印第安人健康研究所（Urban Indian Health Institute）的主持人。它是全国12个部落流行病学中心之一。埃科霍克表示，很明显，原住民受新冠疫情的 disproportionate 影响，甚至仅从轶事来看，正如她所说，
Everybody knows somebody, but that it is impossible to know just how much. Even when data was collected, they weren't collecting the race and ethnicity of American Indians and Lasca Natives and many other people of color. So while we know the impact in our people was great with the scarce data we had, we know it's a gross underreporting. And what's interesting is that the COVID pandemic has recently focused people's attention on this issue. Like, this is something people are now talking about, the fact that the pandemic disproportionately affected people of color.
每个人都认识某个人，但要确切知道程度如何是不可能的。即使收集了数据，他们也没有收集美洲印第安人和阿拉斯加原住民以及许多其他有色人种的种族和族裔。因此，虽然我们知道在我们拥有稀缺数据的情况下，对我们人民的影响是巨大的，但我们知道这是一个严重的漏报。有趣的是，新冠大流行最近让人们将注意力集中在这个问题上。就像，这是人们现在正在谈论的事情，即大流行对有色人种造成了不成比例的影响。
But Echo Hawk has been interested in the issue for much longer. Because ever since she started her career in public health, she has seen the ways that native people and other people of color are made invisible in the data. And it happens through a couple mechanisms. One is by virtue of being a small population that can be difficult to gather, quote, statistically significant data about. And I would be in meeting after meeting after meeting where we would be a little asterisk down at the bottom that would say not statistically significant or not
但埃科霍克对这个问题感兴趣的时间要长得多。因为自从她开始公共卫生职业生涯以来，她就看到了原住民和其他有色人种如何在数据中被隐形。这通过几种机制发生。其中之一是由于人口基数小，很难收集到关于他们的“具有统计显著性的数据”。我曾参加过无数次会议，在会上我们只是底部的一个小星号，上面写着“无统计显著性”或“未报告”。
reported on. And so what it was is we were invisible and we were invisible in conversations that policymakers were having. We were invisible when they were allocating resources and what I saw was incredible health disparities and the deaths of my community members, of my family members as a direct result. So that's one way the data around ethnicity is lacking. Another thing that happens is that people will sometimes be given options on a form, like maybe black, white, and other. It's like a limited range.
因此，结果就是我们被隐形了，我们在政策制定者进行的对话中被隐形了。我们在他们分配资源时被隐形了，我看到的是作为直接结果的令人难以置信的健康差距和我的社区成员、我的家庭成员的死亡。所以这是族裔数据缺乏的一种方式。另一件发生的事情是，有时人们在表格上会有选项，比如黑人、白人和其他。这就像是一个有限的范围。
And other might be the only option that applies, so they check that box. That could include Japanese people. It could include American Indians and Alaska natives. It could include other race or ethnicities. And even when you fill that in, they never disegger get it. That means that they kind of put it all together and they just count that other. What that does is it effectively hides what's happening to a particular population of people. And this issue of aggregation and disaggregation is important. So, disaggregating the data just means breaking the data
而“其他”可能是唯一适用的选项，所以他们勾选了这个方框。这可能包括日本人。它可能包括美洲印第安人和阿拉斯加原住民。它可能包括其他种族或族裔。即使你填写了，他们也从不将其细分（disaggregate）。这意味着他们把它们全放在一起，只计算那个“其他”。这样做实际上掩盖了特定人群身上正在发生的事情。这种聚合与细分的问题很重要。因此，细分数据只是意味着将数据
down into smaller units or segments, instead of bundling a bunch of it up together, which is what happens in the other category. It also sometimes happens with people who are multiple races. Say somebody like my children who are Mexican-American and also American-Indian, and they mark on a form Hispanic, they mark American-Indian, and they mark Filipino, because they're also Filipino.
分解成更小的单位或细分部分，而不是把一大堆东西捆绑在一起，这正是“其他”类别中发生的情况。有时这也发生在有多重种族的人身上。比如像我的孩子们那样的人，他们既是墨西哥裔美国人，也是美洲印第安人，他们在表格上勾选了西班牙裔，他们勾选了美洲印第安人，他们还勾选了菲律宾人，因为他们也是菲律宾人。
And when the data is calculated instead, they put them into a category that says multi-race. But they don't just aggregate it in a way that says they are both Hispanic, they are both Filipino, and they are also American Indian and Alaska Native. I mean, anyone could look at this and know that multi-race is a meaningless category that probably doesn't yield very much information at all. Someone could look at this and know that multi-race is a meaningless category that probably doesn't yield very much information at all. That's right. It is not a very useful category.
而当计算数据时，他们却把他们归入一个写着“多重种族”的类别中。但他们并没有以一种说明他们既是西班牙裔、既是菲律宾人、同时也是美洲印第安人和阿拉斯加原住民的方式来进行细分。我的意思是，任何人只要看一眼这个就会知道，“多重种族”是一个毫无意义的类别，可能根本产生不了多少信息。任何人只要看一眼这个就会知道，“多重种族”是一个毫无意义的类别，可能根本产生不了多少信息。没错。这不是一个非常有用的类别。
And what's interesting is that these other broad categories that we use a lot, like Asian American as an example, when that's used in public health data, it hides the fact that Asian Americans are an incredibly diverse group, with very diverse experiences related to health and illness. Finally, Echo Hawk described yet another way that people of color get erased from the data, which is racial misclassification. Racial misclassification is when you go in and instead of asking you what race or ethnicity you are, somebody might look at you and instead check white based on visual appearance. Check black based on visual appearance. Oh wow, so she
有趣的是，我们经常使用的其他广泛类别，比如亚裔美国人作为一个例子，当它被用在公共卫生数据中时，它掩盖了亚裔美国人是一个极其多元化的群体这一事实，他们在健康和疾病方面有着非常不同的经历。最后，埃科霍克描述了有色人种在数据中被抹去的另一种方式，即种族错误分类。种族错误分类是指当你去就诊时，不是询问你的种族或族裔是什么，而是有人看着你，然后根据外表直接勾选白色。根据外表直接勾选黑色。哦，哇，所以她
means that whoever is filling out the form doesn't even ask. Like they just make an assumption based on appearance and they just fill it in. Yeah, that's right. And Echo Hawk says it happens all the time. And it disproportionately hurts people of color by making the data around their existence and their health issues just fuzzy and incomplete. So does Echo Hawk have ideas about how to change the way we collect data so this type of stuff doesn't happen? Yeah, she does.
意思是填写表格的人甚至不问。就像他们只是根据外表做出假设然后直接填写一样。是的，没错。埃科霍克说这种情况一直都在发生。它通过使关于他们存在及其健康问题的数据变得模糊和不完整，不成比例地伤害了有色人种。那么埃科霍克对如何改变我们收集数据的方式有什么想法，以便不再发生这种事情吗？是的，她有。
She talks about decolonizing data. And in addition to basic stuff, like disaggregating data and allowing for greater nuance in race and ethnicity categories. She wants to see communities be more involved in deciding what gets gathered and shared about them. So she talks about how there's a deficit-based framework in public health, where in the case of her community, the data always shows high rates of obesity, high rates of diabetes, you know, health challenges. But she also sees a lot of strengths in her community, strengths that can actually
她谈到了去殖民化数据。除了诸如细分数据和允许种族和族裔类别更具细微差别等基本工作之外。她希望看到社区更多地参与决定收集和分享关于他们的什么内容。所以她谈到了公共卫生中存在一种基于赤字的框架，在她的社区的例子中，数据显示出高肥胖率、高糖尿病率等健康挑战。但她也在她的社区中看到了很多优势，这些优势实际上可以
measurably improve health. And so she'd like to see data gathered around that too. Yes, we need to know the gaps, but we also need to know how do our youth see themselves in the future. If you can see yourself in the future, that's a protective factor against suicidality. We also want to know where their cultural ties are. Are they culturally engaged? Do they have the access to the resources for their cultural engagement? We want to use the strengths of our community, our cultural protective factors. All of those things are things that
切实可测量地改善健康。所以她希望看到围绕这些也收集数据。是的，我们需要了解差距，但我们也需要了解我们的青年如何看待自己的未来。如果你能看到自己的未来，那就是抵御自杀倾向的一种保护因素。我们还想知道他们的文化联系在哪里。他们是否参与文化？他们是否有接触文化参与资源的途径？我们想要利用我们社区的优势、我们的文化保护因素。所有这些都是可以
can be measured and they can be weighted against the gaps. And her bigger point is just that data should serve the community and the needs of the community. It shouldn't just be to study the community and write academic papers about it. It should be actionable and lead to better health for the communities it comes from. Well, this is really fascinating and interesting, Delaney. Thank you so much. And full disclosure, like a lot of people who work at the intersection of health and justice,
被衡量的事情，并且它们可以与差距进行权衡。她的更宏大的观点是，数据应该服务于社区和社区的需求。它不应该只是为了研究社区并撰写学术论文。它应该是可操作的，并为它所来源的社区带来更好的健康。嗯，这真的很吸引人也很有趣，德兰妮。非常感谢。顺便坦白一下，就像许多在健康与正义交叉领域工作的人一样，
Abigail Echohawk has received funding from the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation, the group that also funded this episode. the group that also funded this episode. 99% of visible was produced this week by Delaney Hall, music by Swan Rial, sound mix by Amidic and Atra, fact checking by Graham Haysha. Kurt Coleset is our digital director, the rest of the team includes Vivian Leigh, Joe Rosenberg, Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Lashemadon, Jason De Leon, Martin Gonzalez, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars.
阿比盖尔·埃科霍克获得了罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会的资助，该基金会也资助了这一集。本周的《99%隐形》由德兰妮·霍尔制作，音乐由斯旺·里亚尔（Swan Rial）创作，混音由阿米迪克和阿特拉（Amidic and Atra）完成，事实核查由格雷姆·海沙（Graham Haysha）负责。库尔特·科莱特（Kurt Coleset）是我们的数字总监，团队的其他成员包括维维安·李（Vivian Leigh）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、拉谢马·唐（Lashemadon）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason De Leon）、马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzalez）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）以及我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。
We are part of the Stitcher and Series XM podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org.
我们是 Stitcher 和 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分。现在总部设在潘多拉大厦（Pandora building）以北六个街区。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰美丽的上城区。您可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与有关该节目的讨论。您可以在 Twitter 上 @ 我（Roman Mars）并在 @99PI org 上 @ 该节目。
We're on Instagram and read it too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Thanks again to the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation for underwriting support of this special episode. Keep an eye out for each episode in this four-part series, The Future of Dota-Dota, and remember, if you have a hunch about the future, share it at shareyourhunch.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们也在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上。您可以在 99PI.org 上找到我喜爱的其他 Stitcher 节目的链接，以及 99PI 的每一个往期节目。再次感谢罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会对本特别节目的鼎力支持。请留意这四部分系列节目中的每一集，即《数据之未来》（The Future of Dota-Dota），并记住，如果您对未来有某种直觉，请在 shareyourhunch.org 上分享它。本集节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。